für uns verfolgt den prozess annika rage
sie ist jetzt live zugeschaltet aus
london
hallo annika wie war denn der ersten
prozesstag heute ja der prozess sagt
heute hat eigentlich eine ziemlich große
überraschung dabei denn die ex freundin
von johnny depp
winona ryder und vanessa paradis haben
beide nicht ausgesagt
das war ja eigentlich für heute geplant
wo ein anrainer hatte man von gestern
auf heute verschoben
jetzt steht fest man will die beiden
wohl nicht mehr
dazu schalten per video sie sollen nicht
mehr aussagen weil die suns sagt dass
man nie angerichtet hat dass johnny depp
die beiden nie geschlagen hat oder
handgreiflich dingen gegenüber geworden
ist dh deren bei die aussage der beiden
ist halt nicht notwendig dafür hat aber
sein sicherheitsmann schon bett aus
gesagt jetzt noch mal drei fotos gezeigt
aus dem dezember 2015 auf dem zu sehen
ist dass johnny depp rötungen im gesicht
hat um kratzer und die sollen beweisen
dass amber heard diejenige gewesen war
die handgreiflich geworden ist da gab es
aber ein paar probleme mit den daten der
sicherheitsmann hatte gesagt das waren
zwei verschiedene vorfälle amber heard
anwälte sagen aber es war nur dieser
eine vorfall und den bestätigt einmal
hört selbst sogar und amber hört soll
sich ja morgen äußern und wo wohnen sie
ihn aktuell überhaupt in london
ja immer hört wohnt in soho eigentlich
so dem dynamischen viertel hier in
london
also hier sind viele schwulen und lesben
bars hier sind wohl es viele restaurants
also es ist wirklich eine vibrierende
gegen ganz anders als bei johnny depp
und wir schauen uns das mal an also hier
hinter mir ist das hotel hier in diese
straße rein geht das hotel da steht
gerade ein bentley vor wir müssen jetzt
nicht ob der dazu gehört die zimmer
kosten so zwischen 500 und 2000 euro die
nacht und in dem hotel ist unten auch
noch eine bowlingbahn aus den 50er
jahren also ein ganz ganz buntes hotel
gar nicht mal so schick wie bei johnny
depp aber natürlich immer noch
hochpreisig und wenn wir jetzt hier die
straße runter gucken ist gleich so zwei
minuten fußweg piccadilly circus zu
erreichen das ist ja so vergleichbar mit
dem time square in new york mit großen
werbetafel
und auch der weg zu johnny depps hotel
vierter lang und wenn wir uns jetzt noch
weiter drehen ist hinter uns praktisch
der weg zum gericht da würde es zu fuß
so 1,2 kilometer gehen 1,5 kilometer
und wenn wir noch ein stück weiter gehen
wenn sie hier die straße runter geht
kommt sie zu ihrer lieblingsbahn in der
sie vor paar tagen mit freunden gesehen
wurde und zwar das ost falls das ist ein
privater club und da kosten weinflaschen
teilweise also bzw teuerste flasche
kostet 7000 euro umgerechnet und ist
eine bar für weinkenner aber auch einen
privatclub das heißt ein wird vorne die
tür aufgemacht von jemandem der dann
auch kontrolliert dass man auch mitglied
ist und da wurde sie jetzt gesehen also
im bad genießt das leben hier und den
trubel während johnny depp sich wirklich
eher zurückzieht